hello everyone and welcome to the first
game of day 4 of the aim chess rapid
it's The Clash of not leaders Duda is
the leader after day three but uh both
of them have been doing very well
throughout the entire tournament and
both of them I have been playing games
which are just incredible especially
mamajaro he's been creating uh
Brilliance after brilliancy that's why
this is such a big clash it's a it's a
very nice game so let's dive straight
into it another of the world rapid
Champion opens with Pawn to D4 uh we
have Pawn to D5 Knight to F3 Knight to
F6 and now Pawn to C3 not as all not as
a common but still uh played quite a lot
sorry about that
uh we have G6 by Mama Dr of preparing to
think into the dark Square bishop and
Bishop to F4 sort of a sort of a London
system set up here Bishop to G7 Ponte E3
and now mamidarov castles with Bishop to
E2 and now Pawn to C5 uh we have Castles
by another back and uh Shakir goes for
Knight to C6 Knight B to D2 so just
putting pieces on optimal squares and
now Knight to H5 going after the bishop
here here as that's a very strong piece
uh Bishop to G5 now not going for Bishop
to G3 right away so now my middle can
exchange it first of course um another
big will force Shakira to weaken his
King side H6 Bishop to H4 G5 Bishop to
G3 and now uh there are some games for
Knight captures and G3 were played but
here we have C captures on D4 and it is
now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game
uh so he captures on D4 you have to
capture either with the epon or with the
c Pawn if you want the open C file
you're gonna capture with the c pawn and
another big decides to keep the the
structure on the queen side intact uh
and now Pawn to F5 threatening Pawn to
F4 to trap the dark Square Bishop so
Bishop to E5 and now finally Knight
captures on E5 Shakira wins The Bishop's
Fair Knight captures and now uh you
could allow this Knight to remain here
with something like Knight to F or you
could continue pushing with G4 but he he
gives up the bishop Bishop captures on
E5 and okay D captures an E5 and now
Knight to F4 putting pressure on the on
the light core Bishop here we have
Knight to F3 and now Queen to C7
uh preparing to dislodge the night with
the G4 and then gobble up the E5 Pawn so
Rook to E1 now inviting the queen to
capture after the Knight is dislodged
and then maybe of uh or threatened some
nasty discoveries but mommy Darth says
nope that's perfectly fine Pawn to G4
Knights the D4 and now Queen captures on
E5 and although you could let's say grab
the G for pawn and open up a discovery
towards the black queen uh it doesn't do
all that much for example captures you
can just move Queen F6 and now the
bishop is just hanging if you go back
Pawn to E5 and black has a massive
Center here so instead after Queen
captures an E5 we have Queen to D2 by
another back uh putting pressure on the
Knight also that H6 Pawn is being
x-rayed by the queen so Queen to D6 now
preparing to strike in the center with
E5 and now Knight to B5 trying to take
away all of the squares from the black
queen queen to B8 this is the only
square and now Bishop to F1
and the bishop is nicely controlling the
Knight Here and Now Pawn to A6 chasing
away the Knight Knight the D4 and pawn
to E5 and now uh what do you do uh you
could move the Knight but uh Abdu satrov
was for Pawn to G3 he says all right if
you capture my knight uh for example if
captures I'm just gonna play G captures
on F4 and your king is wide open yes
I've messed up my Pawn structure in
front of the king but this is much more
important so instead after this G3 move
uh what mamidarov should do is play
Knight the G6 and this is the key idea
here after Knight the G6 point is that
after Queen captures uh now you play
King F7 and threaten Rook to h8 and even
if Queen H7 check you have King the F6
looks very odd but that's what you have
to do and then Rook dh8 is coming but in
the game mamidara played a knight the H5
and this is not as clean as this King F7
King to F6 idea so here yeah we have uh
Queen captures on H6 now threatening to
capture the Knight Knight the G7 and now
Rook 8 D1 also also very clean is just
C4 as of course it captures them Bishop
captures with check once this diagonal
opens up uh it's going to be very hard
for black to defend this but Rook 8 to
D1 uh with the the preparation of C4
also is very nice now yes the the Knight
is still hanging here but if you capture
the Knight here then Bishop to G2 and
this is how the bishop comes alive it's
very very hard to to defend with this
for example in Bishop T6 you can even
capture it The Rook captures but Knight
captures no Bishop captures on D5 and
black just falls apart here
so after Rook 8 to D1 Queen to C7 and
now Bishop to G2 this is how of course
he wants to grab the D5 pawn pawn to E4
and only now c4 uh idea being that while
the queen can capture on C4 if you
capture with the queen on C4 then rookie
three and then the Rook gets lifted all
the way up the board and uh well uh
hopefully uh you can Checkmate the the
black king but after C4 Mama Duro just
plays D captures on C4 and now comes a
move that is just very very beautiful
yeah it's not even in in the engine's
top three recommendations that's why
it's so amazing and that is Rook
captures on e4 just giving up a full
Rook uh to open up lines of attack
towards the black king and okay you have
the capture there's really not all that
much you can do captures Bishop captures
and now you have access to the H7 square
but is it really game over well unless
finds the only line that saves the
position for him and then yes it's over
and the momentarov plays Rook to F7 and
this is not a move that saves the game
the only way to save the game and I will
show it because it's such a fine forcing
line is Bishop to F5 this stops Bishop
to H7 or queen to H7 and the F5 square
is defended sufficiently and now if
Bishop to D5 check now you play Rook to
F7 probably why my medarov played Rook
to F7 uh right away he was maybe
thinking of Bishop D5 at some point but
now after Knight captures an F5 Knight
captures attacking the queen queen G5
check Knight goes back and now Rook the
D4 going after the C4 Pawn going after
the G4 pawn and it's very hard for black
to unwind here but you don't really have
to for example Rook E8 and now okay you
can play something like Rook to F4 uh
put pressure on the on the Rook here
Rook the E7 and now even Rook captures
and G for your threat and Checkmate
because the Rook on F7 is pinned so
Queen to E5 you guard against Checkmate
and now you trade Bishop characters King
captures on F7 Queen to G6 check let's
say King to G8 and now Rook captures on
C4 and you have this position where
Mommy jar would be up at night but uh
another back would be up three pawns so
all in all it's a it's a draw uh but uh
only if my major finds this exact line
starting with Bishop to F5 he didn't he
played Rook to F7 right away now hoping
for maybe something like Bishop to D5
but Bishop to H7 with check is what um
another goes for and now King to f8 and
it seems like you were able to escape
but there is a very very specific set of
moves that allows another Beck to take a
full point here so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for Abu
saturov while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
have to take away these squares from the
black king and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is best of the
G6 this is the only move that wins the
game and now it's very hard for for
black to find the move Rook D1 is coming
and uh one's Queen to h8 lands that will
be Checkmate uh so like something like
Rook to D7 you want to save The Rook
rookie one and there's no defense
against Queen to h8 not the bishop and
The Rook cover all of these squares so
in the game Queen the E5 was played this
is uh mamidara's way of stopping Rook to
E1 but it doesn't matter here another
back took some time to calculate if
everything was
um uh working properly but he calculated
well and he just plays King the F1
and uh now there there's no way to stop
Rook D1 you don't even care that the
Knight hangs because this Knight is not
um involved in the attack whatsoever and
it's uh uh hard to again find the move
Queen the F6 is played which is very
nice now if you continue Rook D1 you
just get checkmated of course none of
you missed that uh so instead Queen to
h8 with check with King the E7 and now
Knight to C6 with check uh just opening
up the entire D file for The Rook so if
the Knight is captured this is just a
very nice Checkmate in two queen to D6
with the check so after Knight the C6
check mamidarov goes King to E6 but now
Knight to d8 with check just connecting
with the Rook on F7 nicely King the E7
and now Knight captures on F7 we have
Queen captures and G6 and now Knight to
E5 you don't want to give check right
away then the Knight hangs so first
Knight E5 now you're attacking the queen
so there really isn't all that much you
can do you would love to move this
bishop to open up the back rank for the
Rook but this comes with checks so you
have to move the queen queen to F6 and
now Queen to d8 check and it was in this
position on move 38 that Shakir ma
Madero resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here once the
king moves and this is the only Square
for your king you're gonna play Rook to
D6 trick King to F5 now Queen captures
on F6 with tracking to E4 and now uh
well uh you can play a whole lot of
moves but Queen to F4 is just made in
one
so there we have it very nice game
between both another back and and
Shakira they've been having an amazing
tournament uh but in this game it was
norweg abusatro of who is better who uh
closes in and do the the leader of the
tournament uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
wish a very happy birthday uh to dhanush
and also a very happy birthday to
pedrino and I would like to thank Lord
of Chess Anderson Vera and torko's
tanguist for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day